We're going to be building this app
in stages across four lessons in
this course.
And we'll come back to this course map
periodically to track our progress.
In lesson one we're
going to learn about how to show
multiple screens in your app.
We're going to leave the other screens
blank temporarily and dive into
the fundamentals of how Android
handles user touch events in your app.
So in lesson two, we're going to
display a list of words in the app.
We'll show the English and
Miwok translations for each word.
And this involves
learning about arrays and
lists, which are Java data
structures to store data in our app.
Then in lesson three,
we're going to improve upon the list, so
we can show images in
the lists alongside each word.
Once this functionality works,
we're going to make visual changes.
Color, font style, spacing so
that the app looks more like
the design marks we are given.
In Lesson four, we're going to add
the play icon to each list item and
learn about the media player in Android.
So we had Andrew record audio files
on how to pronounce each MiWok word.
So we'll play each MP3 file when
the user clicks on a list item.
And at this point,
we have a fully functioning app.
As we mentioned earlier,
there are many ways to build this MiWok
language app, so we want to show you
another way to modify the app to
have a different navigation flow.
In lesson five, we'll integrate all four
lists of vocabulary words into a single
activity, made of four different
fragments that you can swipe through.
There are also tabs across the top, and
this is a common pattern in Android apps
that we thought you might find useful.
For example,
the Google Play store uses this design
when allowing users to
browse through apps.
So while the focus of this course is
on building a MiWok language app,
the skills you learn here can easily
be transferred to any other app.
By the end of this course, you'll know
how to create a app with multiple
screens, display lists of data,
play audio files, and
you'll become more comfortable with
Java oriented programming concepts.
These fundamentals will help you
build more complex Android apps
with even better user experiences.